si el shipping rayo tiene 83 años es el
más viejo en la corte suprema de los
nueve magistrados de la corte suprema
este es uno de los tres liberales los
otros seis son conservadores y los
analistas políticos están diciendo que
precisamente porque es el mayor muchos
liberales lo empujaron a que renunciara
para que el presidente bailén tuviera la
opción de nombrar a un juez de la corte
suprema más joven que pueda durar
décadas en la corte suprema en esa ala
liberal de la corte suprema y pueden
asegurar así un voto liberal en
decisiones tan importantes que se vienen
próximamente y a propósito de lo que
usted nos dice quién podría hacer ese
reemplazo de prayer
pues yo bailé en campaña aseguró que iba
a nombrar si tuviese la oportunidad a
una mujer afroamericana y hay dos
opciones principales la primera es que
tansy brawn ella es el juez de la corte
de apelaciones del distrito de columbia
s
y la segunda opción es y honor a krueger
ella es juez en california las dos
tienen no más de 50 años y aseguraría
entonces precisamente eso que un juez de
corte liberal esté en la corte suprema
durante varias décadas de cara a la
salida de steven reid